- car quelques minutes seulement mais
sûr qu'à madame que vous allez tout
comprendre
en ce moment qu'à madame c'était un one
man aux états unis il avait déjà tourné
film aux etats-unis aussi il est
beaucoup là bas un peu comme son aîné
gad elmaleh c'est son rêve d'aller
là-bas en france il cartonne avec allah
de la presse people
enfin les journalistes l'ont vu aux
états unis en vue son one man notamment
ils l'ont massacré
regardez ce qu'ils ont dit non c'est
autour d'elle à 2 d'arriver dans les
salles obscures avec un qu'eva dams au
top de sa forme au caire malgré plus
d'un million d'entrées en france les
critiques américaines ont visiblement
passé un sale quart d'heure
hollywood riz porter par le d'un film
craquements regardable et pointe du
doigt kev adams qu'ils estiment pas
drôle c'est même pire
selon eux c'est toute la carrière de
l'acteur qui est un couac au point de se
demander comment ces oeuvres doute
mauvaises ont pu rapporter dans d'argent
[Musique]
4 c'est d'autant plus triste que
l'acteur français rêvaient de traversée
de l'atlantique pour y poursuivre sa
carrière
il va peut-être temporiser un peu
finalement et vous vous le trouvez dur
ce verdict alors le verdict est il dur
ou pas la presse américaine donc est
vraiment là la massacrer non mais c'est
quoi ces américains voilà ce qu'ils ont
dit quand même pas le hollywood reporter
le vrai problème ici c'est cave adams
l'acteur ne semblons pas née tout
simplement pardon pas drôle il est
peut-être sympathiques comme il pourrait
être le comme pourrait l'être une
marionnette vous apprennent à lire avec
ses cheveux vigoureusement recouvert de
gel qui semble être à la fois sa marque
de fabrique et sa raison d'être
l'aidant à se dire surtout les jeunes
français et personne d'autre c'est la
reine très violent c'est là où la presse
pardon la presse people atteint ses
limites c'est un type du sivu un
magazine people
hollywood reporter c'est un correspondre
un correspondant du goût de reporter à
paris qui a lu une cave adams et c'est
la mairie s'en prend à cava dames myriam
maintenant mais c'est là c'est là où on
est dans le grand n'importe quoi c'est
est ce que c'est un type qui dit je
n'aime pas beaucoup alors que
bizarrement le même journal sur à la ddt
dans le premier opus avait dit c'est pas
mal et il s'en sort plutôt pas mal
donc la presse américaine est plutôt dur
il ya beaucoup de jalousie
c'est vrai que le garçon il est pressé
il a envie quand même d'y arriver
dernièrement comment dire / / / gad
elmaleh aux états unis ils ont dit que
son spectacle c'est un spectacle de mer
dans le public le washington post il dit
ces mauvais c'est bien ils sont très
durs les américains en tant que trader
je crois même qu'ils avaient à l'étendre
cassé mais marion cotillard mais oui à
devenir des américains lambert
marion cotillard n'a jamais bien joué
pourtant l'air à cames un peu partout
deux des français ils disent que franck
dubosc est indéfendable
il est capable de courir tous les films
où il se trouve donc si vous voulez dire
ce qu'on veut ce verset qui les barreaux
et puis même louvre américain n'est pas
du tout le même qu'en france même les on
le voit tout le temps les carrières
française mais aussi de le faire avec
l'humour aux états unis ça n'a jamais
marché
après lui il a construit sa carrière
avec des fans ici des jeunes qui n'est
pas la même cible du closing du tout
propre à l'homme seul l'air que chez
nous le ramener en france les déférer
lyonnais et le garçon qui est écrit aux
banques par balles à l'estomac mais j on
les connaît pas la part qu'elle ne
connaît pas les humoristes américains et
eux ne connaissent pas gavalda cavada
pendant que les uns gay par la presse
américaine j'ai cru à une blague qui
s'intéressé aux était déjà super huit
cent mille entrées en une semaine avec à
la deux et quand même un talent un truc
de dingue
et là ce monsieur là ne sais pas qui
c'est un journaliste américain en france
et pas j'en suis ravi de sa tête
aujourd'hui à l'antenne et je pense que
ça a servi à ça il écrit aussi l'envié
il écrit aussi dans libé de côté les
amis catherine depuis qu'elle est
d'essayer de bien entendu le temps
accordé à des gens qui ont élu donald
trump à l'écart et on s'en fout là ça
peut être une conclusion mais c'est la
conclusion crs et et quoi qu'il en soit
que adams a grandit tellement tellement
vite et tellement haut et il peut être
très très fier aujourd'hui en fait